guys I have a crazy question Porsha you
are killing it right now is it wrong for
a man to report fraud after a date with
a woman who didn't disclose that she was
trans
oh my God
Michelle that's not a woman
so yeah it's fruits could you argue that
that's also if anything will happen that
that's simple or s-a yes yes yes 100 if
if I've gone into a situation thinking
that I'm going to this situation
thinking that's a woman and there's a
sexual like a biological woman yeah a
biological woman and there's a sexual
aspect to that interaction yes that that
is not only is that sa that's to me
that's Criminal what do you guys think
ladies
it's a mad situation um
Madness your bisexual does how like how
does it
um yeah I'm bisexual I've Got Friends
from the trans Community none that would
not disclose stuff but that to me is
wild it's unfair because obviously if
you're someone already in the LGBT
community then you're gonna be you may
be more open-minded to these things but
you need to disclose I think it's
important it'll be like someone not
disclosing they've got a whole family or
a wife or these are core things that
need to be discussed
um especially if you're straight so I
mean reporting someone for I mean I
don't know there must be some sort of is
it essay possibly it's very weird like
the thing is you're speaking from you're
speaking from a female point of view
let me ask a question though are we
saying that this person has gone through
a transition or that they're just
doesn't matter yes
so let's let's take it to the extreme
just for this argument
dude chopped off his thing
yeah and as has the whole surgery did
everything looks just like like some
something no you look like women yeah
so so so so
Eddie goes on a date with a girl
blessing don't have that meat in mind
okay let's say Joe Joe Average Joe goes
on a date with a girl he's taking this
girl's out of my league she's hot right
he takes her home after the date they
hook up
he doesn't know that like she's got the
surgery and everything yeah it's wild
um
so is that essay because it's not or
fraud but is it that it's non-consensual
that the person's not who you thought
they were yeah
I hear what you're saying no I'm asking
exactly I'm asking would you say it is
or it isn't
it it is it is but it are you not he
there could be many reasons why I'm not
who you say you are ah just don't give
excuses for that it's not an excuse she
asked me a question
about it right in this moment yeah
it's a very techy situation yeah I'm
sure it happens a lot that's how people
die seriously I didn't want to say I'm
happy you said it yeah that's how people
die because people get [ __ ] up like
doing that [ __ ] I hope I never see you
again rightly so because that shouldn't
that's why yeah like people actually die
like if people get themselves into
really crazy situations if if you're
gonna not disclose the fact that you are
jeans and you are gonna interact with me
and I'm thinking that you are a woman
and then I found out that you're
actually not listen that is a very messy
situation for for a quote-unquote woman
to be in that's a courageous era I'm
telling you because a lot of men will be
like what the [ __ ] is what and you can
get yourself into some serious [ __ ] with
that I wonder what the law is on what do
you think I think I think you're right I
think you should just I think they
probably should be disclosing it as well
so if they don't is it a crime
um
I don't know I don't know what to say
about that I haven't really got
an answer I don't think it I don't think
they should be done for fraud if I'm
honest I think that's a bit much but um
I feel like that's light because the
other option is great for essay you
could so say like say if I had a partner
and I was having unprotected sex with
them thinking I was in a committed
relationship but they was cheating
unprotected then then surely that should
be something as well because I'm only
having unprotected sex consensually
thinking it's just us two so if my
partner was having was cheating
unprotected or whatnot then surely that
could be under that as well so so you um
so so you think that a guy lying to
someone about his gender saying that
he's always
I'm just you you said it you said it
under the house would you say it would
you say you you think it's similar
similar I think anxiety in about
anything to get something that you know
a guy cheating is I know I think lying
about anything
anything where you know there's a chance
that if you tell the truth you're not
going to get what you want then I don't
think you should be doing it no there's
levels alone that's it there's levels
there's levels to everything okay like I
think there's okay
cheating right I I put that but if
you're doing it that's exactly you're
putting someone's Health at risk okay
okay okay so that's that's wrong right
you could argue that whatever but then
then there's there's not telling someone
your gender yeah this goes can I just
say something before we go into a whole
other episode this is now going into
transwise gender yeah like gender if
someone's had a reassignment then are
they this and that so it's going it's a
whole different ball game okay I'll
bring it back uh yeah sorry I'm only
just being conscious of that yeah
exactly that's what I was trying to say
that's why you already lost your
Instagram
I'll bring it back I've got
um oh basically
um The Guardian was saying it's actually
gone off my phone at the moment the
guardian was saying
um that dating apps are more beneficial
from for a certain caliber of men than
they are for women women generally
get benefit from dating apps but there
are certain as we lacked or not as we
say on this on the show the top 20 of
men is beneficial for them
um
as women
do you think that when you were on the
dating app do you think that you were
looking for the same type of man that
every other woman were looking for
I don't know what they're looking for do
you know what I mean I'll just look what
I I see what I like it's not really it
is what it is everyone's got different
tastes you know what does your ideal Man
look like
[Music]
I don't know I wouldn't say a certain
height that what's the minimum height
that you date my height probably I'm
five five so my heart you'd better get
your daily do you how many okay last
last two three X's how tall were they
they um were like five eight five nine
okay so they were both five eight five
nine yeah about that the um my first
boyfriend was was taller but the the
last two yeah they've been they haven't
been that much taller than me no like a
couple of inches okay but so it sounds
like they're a similar height yeah but
what about saying that what about being
with two that blow it's like day two
what about what about race same race no
mixed they were they both mixed not like
mixed races but it's it's just a mix
that I'm not I'm not a racist so I'm up
for
attack
I was on a daily basis on this platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible